et
[Musique]
les shadoks dans un double souci d'ordre
et d'organisation scientifiques sont en
train de ranger la paix mais il n'y
arrive pas il n'y arrivait pas parce que
vous vous demandez bien compte que
transporter par exemple une montagne où
un bras de mer d'un bout à l'autre de la
terre
même en courant d'arrache-pied cela
prenait plusieurs générations vous
arrivez en principe à destination les
déménageurs shadoks étaient obligés d'en
porter avec de leur oeuf
[Musique]
mais ça marchait rarement parce que le
shadow cnpf n'était pas au courant
il ne savait pas du tout ce qu'ils
transportaient et il repartait de
n'importe quel côté de sorte que les
choses n'arrivait jamais ou bien quand
elle arrivait s'était jamais au bon
endroit
[Musique]
et cela durera comme ça pendant des sons
et des sens nous ne nous appesantir ont
pas plus qu'il n'est descend sur cette
lamentable affaire de déménagement se
fend d'une des dépôts des poupées lire
les plus illustres aînés plus noires de
l'histoire des shadoks qui en comportait
déjà pas mal
nous passerons donc rapidement sur les
quelques 2600 épisode de notre
feuilleton qui retrace cette lamentable
histoire bisons ont résumé que grâce aux
shadoks la terre épousa pendant ce temps
là des formes de plus en plus diverse
inattendu et saugrenues et son ton au
dessus d'un afag 3200 douzième épisode
ce jour là c'était le petit matin j'ai
gêne un peu gay sortait de la fête chez
l'egypte et il vit
la terre croise sa terre sa terre qui
n'avait pratiquement plus figure humaine
alors saisi la plus terrible colère
c'est que jamais et pour mon là et pour
la la dette les shadoks smirt a créé un
mois creux mais encore une fois du lait
récit quitte à montlaur dalil prises et
prirent le chemin de la lune
[Musique]